hey I'm shailene woodley and I'm Jamie
Dornan and today we're doing the wire
[Music]
what Jamie Dornan what what is Jamie
Dornan favorite suit oh this makes me
just feel so um it's a perfect burger
like I'm a I'm a burger fiend like I
love burgers I can't you know call us
constantly looking for the search of the
best one dude me too
no meat the best burger I've ever had is
in New Zealand
oh really yeah which is amazing but also
so far what school did Jamie Dornan go
to I heard the school in Belfast in
Northern Ireland called Methodist
College Belfast which Mitch's signed
berry sort of religious I didn't I did I
came out of it not religious I'm not
serious
what does Jamie Dornan look like now
what do you look like what languages
does Jamie Dornan speak um honestly
terribly doctor speak English I speak a
wee bit of French like enough to get me
by and even buy groceries and stuff if
I'm in France but I'm just thinking what
is Jamie Dornan zodiac sign does that
mean just your star sign is that the
same thing yeah that's usually hi not
entomb of that I am I'm a Taurus as I've
seen my birthday I don't know when this
is going to my birthday tomorrow so I'm
I'm a Taurus okay is shilling Woodley a
vegetarian
no is Shailene Woodley dating someone
No I'm dating myself actually
this is a good one Shailene Woodley
Hawaiian no I am NOT Hawaiian by blood
but I do feel that those islands are my
home so because of the descendants
that's when I first went to Hawaii and
then I stayed for a few years
here's the question you've what the
chalene is shilling would they
left-handed no I'm not my mom saw salmon
but I'm not left-handed same name would
be British
I actually am I'm like 89% like
genetically from England all of my
ancestors are from there and then West
Africa those are the two places that I'm
from um obviously I am English but I
mean I'm not British I'm American I feel
like I feel like this year had this
pandemic what happened you were about to
play like back-to-back British people am
i right okay does Jamie Dornan have an
accent what if we don't just Jamie
Dornan of a hotel you're reading I don't
know does Jamie Dornan wear glasses I do
if I'm if I'm reading for a long time
not if I'm reading like a menu or
something I'm ground put of them if I'm
reading like a script or a book and I
know I'm gonna be reading for more than
sort of 20 minutes I I wear glasses you
does Jamie Dornan I have a dog
I do you have a dog yeah we do with a
family dogs go Leonard
Lenny he's a black lab and he's three
years old and he's he's beautiful
was amazing
oh my god this is me to type this into
Google um why was feeling Woodley in
jail
um I was in jail because I was picked
out of a group of 400 people well at
Standing Rock reservation a few years
ago when thousands and thousands people
are protesting a very dangerous pipeline
um and I was like Facebook
live-streaming and there were like tons
of people watching what was happening at
the moment and the cops picked me out of
the crowd because I was trespassing and
that's why I was arrested why shailene
woodley environmental activist
I uh I mean I don't you know I really
don't like that word activist I feel
like it separates people and says one
person is doing better than another
person we're all just doing the best we
can and I happen to not have kids and I
happen to not have you know a lot of
responsibilities in my life so I can
generate a lot of my energy towards the
environment and towards protecting it so
that when I do have kids they can
survive in a good way and then their
kids can survive in a good way and I
just think it's important too you know I
think it's important to give back to the
thing that has given us the most which
in my opinion is the earth
why shaming Woodleigh romance movies by
my in romance movies cool that's what
we're gonna go I love love I don't know
um also there's just a lot of
opportunities for women my age to the in
romance movies and not a lot of
opportunities to do other things I'd say
that those are probably the number one
like most available projects to be a
part of unless you just want to be like
a girlfriend in the background or a
flight stewardess so that's probably why
I've done so many romance movies but
also because I love I just love love
why Sheila Woodley the OSI uh also
doesn't make sense but I I was in the
OSI I was 13 years old when I was 11
years old
played Mischa Barton little sister and
then I was replaced when I was 13 by
different actors to play the same
character because I hadn't gone through
puberty yet and they really they needed
a girl who had a body and who had I mean
really that's what it was they needed
somebody who had a body that was
different than mine
but you know it's okay I didn't really
take offense to it I was a late bloomer
and it's fine jeepers jeepers um if
Jamie Dornan Irish yes I am true fact is
Jamie Dornan in a quiet place like the
movie is Jamie Dornan in Outlander Danny
why are you in all of these movies and
shows that or did you just pretend like
you're with the family but you're
sneaking and I have not stopped working
like Glenn Close and hook kind of yeah
yeah I just wrapped the right lounder
season six what a trip those feeling
Woodley have Instagram yes I do those
really Woodley sing too much probably I
mean listen we've sung together we have
sang together Christmas songs
mm-hmm door shailene woodley have
tattoos I actually do um I got that I
got two tattoos last year my body
rejected them I feel like I'm probably
the only person on the planet who's ever
gotten tattoos and body my body decided
to say no I got this one which is very
difficult to see I had it done twice and
it's still like chipping away and then I
got like a Nate a word on my finger that
you can't see it all and I uh I got that
done twice as well and it's it's
completely gone so I guess I'm just not
meant to actually have tattoo
because my body we have a phone actually
do right now I have a phone right now
but I do go through phases where I don't
have one that is do you not check it
very often or are you pretty good to
check it it's not that I don't even
check it very often I just like I mean
let's see I have 150 200 text messages
who knows how many what's up I don't
know it's I just I just don't like it I
don't like it I'd rather hang out with
someone in person than talk to them over
the phone which is completely irrational
but what is Jamie Dornan doing right now
well you know I'm I'm zooming her dear
friend shailene woodley and we're
talking about the internet you know I'm
gonna put my kids I've got a window they
do this nice thing here to in lockdown
at 8 o'clock
everyone goes outside their house and
claps for the image which okay yes our
National Health Service which I have
just missed by seven minutes but um we
Li are older two kids to stay up for it
and so they're right at the front of our
house trapping and banging pots and pans
and raining barrels and stuff and then
I'll go and put them to bed when this is
done that's what I'm doin er my
nationality is Jamie Dornan kind of feel
like we've had this but um I'm yeah I'm
Irish - what age is Jamie Dornan well
what a question that is given the timing
because I don't know when this is gonna
I the moment I'm 37 and tomorrow on
Friday the 1st of May I turned 38 what
height is Jamie Dornan um 6 foot tall
maybe like less than half a centimeter
below that but that's rounded up is
always my what was Jamie Dornan first
movie I a very lucky the first movie I
ever
it was Marie Antoinette with Sofia
Coppola it was my first ever audition
I just got an agent I just decided that
I kind of wanted to act and Sofia I mean
it literally just won like an Oscar
maybe two Oscars for loss of translation
so it was a crazy crazy first job
very cool what is shailene woodley doing
no I'm petting my dog and I'm into my
friend over zoom what is
Woodley in AI well I'm in pajamas so I
don't know if that's the answer you are
probably not getting what is sitting
with his Instagram shailene woodley not
very creative what was shooting with
these first movie huh is a movie called
replacing dad I did it when I was 5
years old and I remember I remember the
director told man has a certain tile on
the bathroom floor that we are filming
in and I came out of this bathroom stall
and I realized that I hadn't hit the
tile so as I'm doing the scene I'm
scooting myself across the floor that
tile when they kept it in the movie it's
the funniest thing first thing I'm doing
tonight